and it was really about this issue of
the competition between climate change
and poverty reduction in your work at
the foundation are you finding that
competition
are you finding one is driving out the
other more particularly of late and what
are you gonna do about it thanks Tony
Tom thanks for doing this
my pleasure means a lot to all of us at
the morning talk it was almost like we
was set up between Allen bono Antipodes
of a conversation
climate change versus poverty the funds
the discussion the public concept and it
was all about a gas an atmospheric gas
but I thought it was not about covering
tax I thought the oxygen because it's
true that climate change takes all the
oxygen out of the room and it takes all
the momentum out of people who spent
their life committed working against
poverty and it shouldn't be like that
not only are the poor in the developing
world the greatest victims of climate
change but if we don't grow economic
development in the right way they will
contribute as in China and in India to
climate change in a way that we won't be
able to to bring it back so I can't
imagine a better statement I heard
President Clinton say that the growing
disparity between rich and poor and the
marginalization of poor people it is
unequal unfair unstable and
unsustainable and it contributes to
insecurity around the world we need to
be mindful of all these things you know
the good news I think about our our
generation is that whether we're a DD or
we can parallel process we've got to be
big enough and grown-up enough to be
able to simultaneously handle more than
one threat so what we're doing about it
is we announced five initiatives two of
them are on poverty and go through the
five five-year district also taking it
from poverty first I was in Africa mate
many of you were recognize your faces at
the TED conference there was this big
fight
between aid and trade aid and trade but
if you talk to poor people in the
developing world they're not gonna say I
want more aid more foreign aid they say
I want a job I want to be able to feed
my family and care for my family and I
want government services that work
education for my kids health care
electrification water so we decided that
those were twin halves of the problem of
poverty and economic development so one
of our initiatives is to empower people
not just poor people but you know
starting off with poor people in the
developing world so that they know what
public service is government and other
public services are available and
empower them to take advantage to avail
of and to have access to these services
governments are not bad we have this
illusion that third world governments
are corrupt and incompetent there's some
wonderful governments in the developing
world and sometimes they just don't have
the tools to deliver what they want to
do so the other half is to try to help
governments develop those tools and that
draws on Google's technology and our
information services the other
initiative in the area of poverty is job
creation and two-thirds of all the jobs
in the United States are created by
small and medium-sized enterprises you'd
think it was the same in in the
developing world it's not less than 15%
of all the jobs in the developing world
are created by small and medium-sized
enterprises the bulk of jobs now are
created by these big large corporations
mostly extraction industry so if we can
fire up the small and medium-sized
entrepreneur that's where all the jobs
will come from we hope to be able to
play a role of that in the area of
health and in particularly our pandemics
and emerging communicable diseases there
have been three dozen new diseases that
have jumped from animals to humans in
the last 30 years any one of which under
the wrong circumstances could become
pandemic one of which already has
hiv/aids is a pandemic and it jumped
from monkeys to humans we worry about
bird flu and SARS but there's also Ebola
Lassa fever Marburg if you chant them in
a religious way all these diseases you
realize something's changed and so what
we're trying to do is to fund early
warnings
systems and increase the availability of
good response and then lastly what we
were talking about this morning our
issues in energy and climate change
which Larry and Sergey are going to talk
a lot more about on the one hand we and
I really appreciate Al you saying that
re less than C captures the imagination
of the problem and what Larry said in
the press conference is a little bit
wonky but you know or a little nerdy I
forgot what you said it was something
like that but it really captures the
equation exactly right until you can
create utility grade electricity from
renewable energy at a price cheaper than
coal the coal will be burned I lived in
India ten years every lump of coal will
be burned unless is a cheaper way to
produce electricity so we're really
committed to that and I'll let Larry or
Sergey or both talk about what we're
doing inside of Google to mount an
opportunity to create our own 1 gigawatt
renewable energy production facility the
flip of that equation though is as you
said we have to be able to internalize
the externalities of bad health
consequences of coal because that
equation only works when it's the right
cost the fully loaded cost of coal and
the fully loaded cost of renewables the
last of our climate initiatives is to
try to create a world in which not only
the coal stays in the ground but the oil
stays in the ground the petroleum the
gasoline isn't consumed and that really
means electric cars it might mean
temporarily plug-in hybrids but so long
as you plug into a grid that is mostly
coal you do it you get some marginal
improvements but not substantial
improvements if you have a grid which is
green and you plug into a green grid in
the combination those two things really
deal with almost 50 percent of all of
greenhouse gas emissions so I didn't
need to take so much time but those are
our five initiatives terrific there let
me start with you take us back to your
own internal conversations about re
lesson C which stands for a renewable
energy cheaper than coal why you decided
to go into the energy space it's a big
move for Google
and what do you think a company like
Google could bring to the goal of one
gigawatt of clean power enough to power
San Francisco that maybe others haven't
yeah I think we were really lucky to be
at the intersection of a bunch of
different things being in Silicon Valley
you know we have lots of friends and
companies while working in renewable
energy area we also have this sort of
relentless demand for people on the
internet to do things so people
searching and email and all those things
how did that manifest itself how did you
sort of notice that well we have to buy
computers to hold everybody's email and
everybody searches in the web and and
you know there's huge numbers of
computers and the energy to power those
and you know we we want Google to work
you know you don't want to go to Google
and say oh sorry we're we're busy right
now
that would be really bad you know we
were forced to be very practical about
that and so we've had you know we've had
a team going around building data
centers and finding energy and so on and
so we and doing that worldwide those who
want our services to be fast everywhere
and because of that are we really
noticed well we're getting you know we
have some facilities for example that
are close to dams and so on but a lot of
times we're really displacing somebody
else who would use that energy it's not
that by building a data center next to a
dam if the dam is already being used
maybe you know there's not quite as much
transmission as there would have been
but it's not that that's such a green
way of doing it and you know many places
you know you basically see that you know
we would see and buying a lot of
electricity you know where you get a
cheaply it's from coal and you know the
business side of our company is saying
well you know let's buy the cheap
electricity and make sure you know a
bottom line is good and all that and you
know we're kind of looking this isn't
good right
computers are using more and more
electricity people are doing more things
with them and actually the cost of your
computing that's electricity is going up
as a percentage well it's actually
pretty significant might even approach
the cost of the computers themselves and
because of that we said well why why
aren't we making renewable energy
cheaper then you
got a phone call that would be the easy
decision to make say we're gonna get a
cheaply an you know it's going to be
green and there's tons of startups in
the space we've invested in some we have
friends in many different ones and the
problem we had is that all the startups
they can basically do have an incredible
business making electricity at ten cents
a kilowatt hour and the reason is
there's tremendous demand for renewable
energy and we would buy it at a higher
price but you know you you're not going
to fundamentally change the game unless
the it's cheaper than coal and the
problem for a start-up you know they're
looking at it well we want to succeed we
can make it a $0.10 succeed but we
really need to make it at three cents to
really change the world and we we want
those projects that could be three cents
to start right now and we're willing to
take you know the risks on those things
and obviously if you succeed at one of
those things you're gonna have a great
business well but it's very rational for
a start-up to say we're not going to
take that risk we're gonna take you know
we're gonna produce it at the ten cents
and we're gonna have a great business
and you know we want our business to
grow slowly and our primary goal is not
to fix the world
right whereas we have a little bit of a
luxury of driving some of those projects
forward so I think we saw that there
wasn't enough investment in some of
those things and we also saw how we
talked to enough people that you know if
you really push the startups and the
people who are really smart on these
things say well do you guys have a way
of doing it at three cents they say yeah
we do it a little bit modestly higher
risk however we have a clear path to get
there and we're like well why don't we
get going on that now what do you need
you know you need some people and it's a
little bit of money and so on that's
relatively modest resource so you tell
us a little bit about where the
initiative is right now are you
exploring different clean power
alternatives which ones attract you sort
of where are they and what can a Google
bring to this at an ExxonMobil or
Chevron camp well just first off where
we are right now we highlighted three
areas of renewable energy that we
thought would be good initial focuses
solar thermal also deep
geothermal and rent a good point
high-altitude word I should clarify
specifically why those three certainly
as you winded him down we were looking
at the options around at the time I
think there are potentially a few others
that could make the cut if I had to add
one I would say photovoltaics but I
think these are three that are known
into the renewable energy community but
not broadly kind of thought about and
well understood and currently for
example if you look at wind power the
windmills are on par with coal today now
they're intermittent power you know
since you can't just rely on the wind
always being there but they're already
pretty good we think that it can be even
cheaper by using high altitude wind and
we highlighted one company that we're
working with called Makani these kites
at potentially high altitudes to to
generate and it's you know kites much
cheaper to make than a big metal wooden
oh so that's that's really interesting
one if you imagine getting power that
cheap I mean that could be substantially
cheaper than coal the other one solar
thermal is is pretty well known I mean
you already see these things with the
parabolic trenches and the solar towers
and whatnot and it's something that it
just seems like there's just a little
bit of really basic just engineering and
development to make that be really cheap
I mean there's no inherent barrier in
the way if you kind of you just need so
much mirrored surface and you can kind
of do the math and the existing
companies it's the situation that Larry
said you know they feel that if they can
produce the $0.10 which they take a more
conservative engineering route they'll
still have a great business we want to
push them a little bit more saying you
know we're willing to risk these maybe
being not you know not quite as 100%
guaranteed to pan out but we wanted to
bring it down to three cents or
something like that so just a
technically how you're doing it you've
found a stable of companies in these
different areas and then you've invested
in them
sorry starting up we have done
investment in both solar thermal as well
as the high altitude wind we think that
we should have some of these things
going on in house we don't have the
in-house research going on yet but we
are hiring in those areas and deep
geothermal is actually another example
of one because there's existing
geothermal if you look at Iceland or
something like that and those you know
in those areas that have that that works
pretty well for them that's not
necessarily you know dirt cheap I guess
it's kind of dirt cheap but it's anyway
there's there's reason to believe that
if you go really deep and actually take
advantage of the technology that the 30
industries have created in terms of
drilling and whatnot that you can
actually have geothermal power be cheap
and available almost everywhere and
around the world and and that's really
exciting that's that's a little bit
farther off this is where you don't
really see startups because it requires
more fundamental research there's a
gentleman from our Maps I think is here
oh they have 400 megawatts of geothermal
that they own even so there's a lot of
great work going on in those areas Larry
what Larry Page two questions one is
what is it you you guys have been an
amazing innovation company in the area
of search what's the difference between
doing innovation and something like
search bits and bytes and doing
innovation and something like energy
which is atoms molecules in terms of
being able to really do this kind of
breakthrough innovation what's the
difference working these two areas I
mean I don't find it to be that to
remember we've had a fair amount of work
that's gone on just making our data
centers efficient and actually a lot of
the people and knowledge we've had in
pursuing some of the energy related
things are those people like they're
basically borrowing those people a
little bit from their day jobs and
hopefully Google will still answer your
query and some and we've had just
wonderful people in those areas I think
you know what you need are people who
are willing to take
to take you know a new way of doing
things and and so on and who know enough
about the area to make some progress
what's been the reaction of the energy
companies the Exxon Mobil suddenly they
wake up one morning they read in the
paper that Google's going into the
energy business and these are companies
that have historically Al Gore and I
were talking about this on the way over
you know they're expert at pushing
things into the future and it seems that
you guys actually want to claim the
future now as opposed to always keeping
the future just just 10 years out you
know what's been their reaction III
haven't talked to many of them I would
suspect that the reaction is different
depending on which one like Exxon I
don't know that would be the same as BP
for example but some of these companies
like BP are certainly very interested in
investing in these clean technologies I
think we have a little bit of benefit
that we don't have an existing business
that we're you know worried about
cannibalizing or anything like that you
bring that to a table mm-hmm I do want
to highlight one important difference
between doing like web search and things
like that and the energy business or at
least web search when we started it
right now if you want to prove a success
in energy there's a certain scale you
have to achieve otherwise you can't
demonstrate the cost-effectiveness or
your product and that probably means
putting in you know 100 million dollar
plant or something like that I mean
there's a big bet at some point that you
have to make and takes a lot of capital
and that's we feel that this maturation
or a company that we actually have you
know a fair amount of capital and we're
willing to probably be riskier with it
than other companies like we can take a
chance on a data center I think that
puts us in the position to do things
that other companies wouldn't I'm gonna
get to later brilliant in a second but
apropos of that Larry Page what's been
the reaction of your shareholders I mean
I think it's been fine I think we stated
we stated we would make probably
investments capital investments and
hundreds and millions of dollars that
would be there were generate positive
returns and I think we said just what
sorry I just said we would take some
more risk in those but it would be
modest and we still expect them to net
out positive we're already doing that in
the course of building out our investor
in data centers and so on um so I think
I think that reaction was fine in the
you know in terms of hiring people and
really getting these projects going I
mean those are you know it's see if we
can hire you know a thousand people who
are really excited about doing this we
would but we're not going to find those
people I'm just saying they're brilliant
dumb one of the things we talked about
at the morning session is I've always
had this feeling it's much more
important to change your leaders in your
lightbulbs because leaders write rules
rule shaped markets markets give you
scale but one of the problems you know
we've had you almost couldn't make this
up and um people don't realize because
it was actually badly reported we just
passed an energy bill where we threw out
the incentives or we did not include the
incentives for wind and and solar and we
maintained those for oil gas and coal
Mitt Romney just won a Michigan primary
in the Republican Party by promising to
get rid of the mileage standards just
passed by Congress that is dumb as we
want to be that you could not make that
up but we just did that now how how do
you um succeed in this space without
taking part in the editorializing but I
don't have a column now and I had to get
it out you know um but what I really
think
but can you succeed in this space I'm
interested in all three of you without
taking more of a political position so
what do they do in law they say I'd like
to incorporate by reference his comments
um you know I I I'm accused often of
being maybe a little rosy eyed I think
your rosy glasses whatever the
expression is where's bono he'll help me
um the people who have fought against
protecting us against climate change a
very very small percentage of more bad
people I mean you'd be disingenuous if
you didn't recognize that something very
small percent who are bad people they
have children they have grandchildren
whether they call it Earth stewardship
or they call it protecting their kids
from
they're good people we have somehow
failed to articulate in the most
compelling way the urgency of the moment
I mean let me just take a moment to say
when we talked earlier about the
conflict between poverty and climate I
think this is an extraordinarily
sophisticated audience but you know I
had a conversation with Muhammad Yunus
has been a friend for 30 years and I
think of his whole body of work five
million women who've had loans all of
them have paid it back because of
microcredit moving into telephony we
have a deal with him where the saver
foundation will do surgery on blind
people and he'll give a microcredit loan
to people who are blind Bangladesh and
the rest of the world has benefited from
everything he's done all of which will
be washed away if you have a see rise of
three meters so it you can't separate
the quest for dignity and fight against
poverty and climate change and I think
that and so he gets it now Muhammad
Yunus gets it people working in the
development world get it they know that
while they want to battle urgently for
the hurt that poor people feel today you
know the two million who died this year
of malaria they also know that with
climate change it will be 5 or 7 million
dying every year we have failed to get
that degree of awareness and
understanding in Congress and in Senate
and then the political leadership it's
our failure we can't give up on that so
the areas that were taking aim at I
guess because you got to be focused
we're very interested in internalizing
the externalities the negative health
externalities of coal when you dig for
coal you kill people miners die they get
black lung disease they get other
respiratory disease that children and
our children miss school we miss work
for Spira Tauri diseases caused by coal
you only have to be in Beijing for a
moment to understand that so the
regulatory issues the the policy issues
about how we truly a call what's the
true cost
for coal it's not just the marginal cost
of extracting one number call its what a
society paid for it I liken it to the
second-hand smoking issue and that's why
I think we can only reframe the debate
though so you you get you know L quoted
these numbers you know this morning of
you know nearly three thousand questions
asked up to now on the Sunday morning
talk shows and in all the debates and
three on climate in this election and
this L said there were three on UFOs so
climate and UFOs are now equal you know
what are we doing what is Google doing
what is the plan to to reframe the
debate well I think Bono said this would
be the fruit maybe also be the first
time that public movement took place in
order to raise taxes if we were trading
something like that I think it's much
more compelling to look at what happened
with second-hand smoking there was a
time how many of you remember when all
the chief executive officers of all the
tobacco companies raised their hand and
said no it doesn't hurt it doesn't hurt
anybody at all I smoked it all the time
you know we need to reframe the debate
we need to understand the negative
consequences of the way in which we are
developing our world and coal is a great
example and that's a role that we can
play we can fund research with credible
researchers who will identify all the
externalities of coal shouldn't be
Google saying we don't like coal it
should be here are the best researchers
in the world and we're gonna give them
grants so they can cost that out those
are the kinds of things I think we can
do far more effective than going to
Washington saying you know we're Google
you got to stop digging for coal that
that that is not going to necessarily
have the desired effect okay Larry
knowing what you guys know now about the
energy business and how we get to scale
we're going to have an election we will
have a new president that proposed that
issue what do you think would be the
most helpful thing in terms of your own
project that the next president him or
her decides on day one around the energy
space what would be most helpful for
getting your project to scale I mean I
don't know the the best possible thing
one thing that I'm very concerned about
is transmission and I just think total
story I went to University of Michigan
and engineering
and like 20 years before I got there
they closed their power transmission
school they had a school that dealt with
high tension wires and power
transmission and that was closed long
long before I got there and you know
unsurprisingly that area hasn't advanced
that much and I'm pretty concerned what
sorry I mentioned about wind is very
true the costs of a windmill the power
is competitive with coal now except for
transmission and the sorry transmission
and the variability and if you have
better transmission that really helps
you with the variability how there's
been studies that show for example
Europe could get 90 percent of their
electricity from wind at a cost equal to
coal 90 percent just from wind at same
cost as coal if they had better
transmission now it's kind of terrible
that there's nobody working on that
right as far as I could tell or very
very few people and even if we did have
technologies that were better for the
transmission the ones we have are
probably good enough to you know solve
Europe's energy needs but the odds that
they'll get deployed you know across a
wide area like that are probably close
to zero without somebody like a US
president or or somebody powerful saying
we're gonna build really good
transmission so that we can have better
renewable energy and solve some of these
problems give us kind of interstate
highway system for the grid yeah right
now you know if you order a transformer
at three years as a expedited delivery
hmm we know that we order transformers
so I think you know in that kind of
environment we're not going to see very
fast progress on solving these energy
issues
so I'd say transmission we should have
we should just assume that we're going
to need better transmission it'd be nice
to you know use more energy than we use
now and how to do renewable and we're
not gonna get any of those things unless
we have better transmission and that's
got to be a governmental issue so you
get other than transmission what would
be yours
what would what do you think the next
president could do that would be most
helpful I think that we want to be on an
equal playing field between renewables
and and coal and dirty energy I think
people kind of under appreciate right
now that I think like well all these
renewables want all these subsidies the
taxes on the dirty technologies but the
situation right now is very opposite of
that if you just look at Larry mentioned
the pulmonary disease effects of coal
not to mention the particulate so say of
a lot of our transportation if you look
at well the Iraq war which whether you
believe that the US and therefore oil or
not certainly the reason that that
Saddam had all that military might was
because of the oil money that we paid if
you look at things like the cost you put
it on renewables the tariffs on
Brazilian ethanol right now because I
would today sure I'd run my car in
Brazilian sugar cane ethanol but but the
tariffs make it prohibitive even though
it's the equivalent of like 30 to 40
dollars a barrel in Brazil today I have
friends who have electric car companies
and if you look at kind of the
regulatory hurdles they have to go
through to get their cars on the road
all the crash testing and whatnot now
it's true that car companies do all the
crash testing on their gas cars but they
don't know the motorcycles and you know
the motorcycles are unsafe so why not a
budding young company can sell you know
a few hundred electric vehicles prior to
having to go through all that which may
very well be very safe and also none of
these car companies are forced to
consider the safety of the people that
they hit you know that's kind of a funny
thing but so I also having you know
we've installed a lot of solar capacity
on our campus about that a little bit
what you've done what you've learned
from your own experience incorrupt row
over a mega 1.6 megawatt something like
that now and we installed them on the
roofs of our buildings as well as we
built car ports and things like that and
you know it's been great I mean creates
shade it reduces our power costs it's
been a good investment but there were a
lot of hurdles and and most of the
hurdles aren't technical and they're not
financial they're just regulatory
you know by the time you got all the
permits to do this that and the other
and these aren't I don't think these are
people sort of conspiring against clean
technology it's just you know by the
time you add up all the federal state
you know local government zoning
planning whatnot it adds up to a really
big burden whereas if you kind of use
status quo technologies you know just
plug me into the grid you know you don't
have to do anything
somebody just shows up the front of mine
recently installed a fiber to those
office building and had to cross a
little creek so I have to put up a post
and all these people showed up but they
had to verify that it would withstand
like 200 mile an hour wind or whatnot
and the guy who erected it who normally
puts it up for the power company their
PG&E said oh yeah PG&E doesn't really
have to listen to any of those
regulations I just put up a bowl you
know I don't have to go through any of
that so there's just all these hidden
barriers to clean energy today that
don't exist for dirty energy and that's
that's that's the truth of the world
since stamps today Larry Page one of the
things that Google that org is trying to
do is unlock entrepreneurship in the
developing world as a way of overcoming
poverty and a lot of people have taken a
crack at that and it failed what do you
think you guys could bring or are
bringing to that initiative that might
make it work where others have failed
well the promises you have left in the
developing world are the really really
hard ones and I tried to take a lot of
vacation time and travel around there
and really understand try to understand
what's going on and you know there's
been already tremendous work by very
many different people a lot of which
runs room care so I think you know we're
going to try to do something something
more we you know we've been running
things like business plan competitions
which I've seen personally some of the
results of and I think I think the
things that I've seen that have been
successful in these areas you know the
arms like massive amounts of labor but
you know it's very careful kind of
seated attempt to just generate a little
bit of knowledge and
people like or you know you should you
should have a business plan you should
think about what you're gonna do and
then compete about it and talk about it
and learn how to do that and what that
what you you started a competition
around business plans talk about that a
little bit I mean that's basically a to
just you just have a local entrepreneurs
you you you know have a big event you
give out a prize a little bit of money
for the winner which gets the winner
probability to get funding and all those
things it's just that whole mechanism
you know until you know in Silicon
Valley this is what people do for
breakfast you know they they they know
how to do that and you know in Kenya or
somewhere they've never seen that before
but once you got that started and you
get a community around it you have you
know a few hundred people involved first
and you got thousands and so on I think
that's how you're gonna make progress
with local people and some idea that
makes sense there and really just
growing that and making it happen and I
do think that you know having a lot of
enterprises I mean there's there's a lot
of things going on in these places but
having a little bit of organized
enterprises having you know some of the
things that we've we've learned how to
do just getting that idea into people's
heads is really important like you you
know you go to these places and you're
like well they don't have any debt
financing you know I was in Ghana for
his Oh personally and they don't have
any debt financing for houses really
you're like well no wonder it's hard for
people to buy houses there's no way to
borrow money to buy a house can't secure
it right we've discovered that's an
important thing right and so sometimes
just getting that idea and and then the
people they're obviously very capable
and they can really run with those
things once they once people know know
about that and know so when you when you
you know made aware of a problem like
that you then call up Larry and say hey
you know is there some way we can get
either financing to local banks or start
our own or what do you do with an idea
like that I mean I think we just try to
talk about them that's not I mean I
think again this these are the problems
that are really hard that haven't been
solved and a lot of people have been
working on them and so there's usually
you know there's usually ten different
things standing in your way you know you
don't have a body of law like I don't
think they're way they do land ownership
there
or a lot of these countries you know you
don't you don't really know who owns the
land or you don't have clear titles it's
hard to have that based on that and so
you know you just run into you know the
reason why it's not solved is because
there's ten things that need to be done
that doesn't mean you shouldn't try to
do those things right mmm Sergey talk
about what you've learned from China and
India in the energy space you obviously
compete you know in China in the field
of search what do you see going on there
that excites your or not about in the
energy field well I think primarily in
China and what was stressed out about
the energy space I mean the number of
coal plants that are going up there I
mean that's that's gonna be a really big
challenge I think it is important for us
to solve the problem in the u.s. kind of
unilaterally and first the head of you
know pushing the developing countries
but I do think that we need to do it
quickly before it's it's too late in
those other countries and I think
there's a lot of reason for hope there
too if I'm going to drift a little bit
further afield to Bhutan which my wife
when I visited a year and a half ago and
you know we kind of you do this treks
there and we hiked up and you know you
go really high you got altitude sickness
you're up in the middle of nowhere and
the only people you run into are these
yak herders they don't really have
anything they just like have a little
tarp they put over a few rocks they have
their yak which are wandering around far
away and they only had one piece of
technology which is well - they had a
solar cell and an LED light it was the
most amazing thing because the first
time the battery else that's where
they'd have a anyway and you walk around
I mean it's really you know you're in a
really you know remote part of the world
kind of up kind of in the sky and that's
what they have there and it makes a lot
of sense first they have a legal system
where they are trying to prevent
deforestation so people can't just chop
down trees to create you know their fire
endless I mean they do allow to take
some and they use that for cooking but
they don't use that for the
just night like that they need and it
turns out to be really even though for
them so I'm sure it's expensive to buy
solar so it's still really cheap
compared to the alternatives and I think
that makes sense in a lot of places
around the world in Africa for example
you know we don't have the transmission
lines you don't have great roads to
transport the diesel fuel and not to
mention it's $100 a barrel now anyway
all these places even at today's photo
will take prices it makes a lot of sense
to install photovoltaics and I think
you're gonna see that trend accelerate
because this technology is becoming
cheaper more ubiquitous and nothing is
really improving in the in the dirty
space they do you notice in terms of
Google Trends and if you've looked at
this or if you can in terms of what are
people searching for terms of solutions
climate change energy clean energy solar
do you see anything showing up there in
Google Trends I think people are
definitely much more aware of these
things and it's hard I think it's hard
for everyday people to know what to do I
mean you have the compact fluorescents
and so on but I think a lot of the
changes that need to get made are the
bigger issues transmission and and you
know bringing down costs and all those
things I want to open it to the floor we
have so many